véronique psychologue ce que je trouve
un peu un peu difficile au quotidien
dans cette pratique c'est surtout la
rencontre répétées de l'impuissance
je fais fait il m'arrive de soignante ce
que je trouve plus difficile c'est donc
la souffrance des familles
je compatis en fait à la france et donc
ça me permet de pouvoir les aider
sandrine médecin alors moi ce que je
trouve le plus difficile c'est là la
prise en charge de gens qui sont
révélées vraies notamment qui ont des
plaies très importante avec donc sur le
plan visuel c'est quand même très
difficile pour moi et sur le plan
olfactif les odeurs sont très
dérangeante pour moi et ça c'est quelque
chose de très difficile donc tout ça sur
le plan physique après sur le plan
psychique sousse et de parfois parié à
prendre assez de distance par rapport à
aux histoires des patients peut-être
parfois ça veut dire un peu trop et du
coup y laisser quelques plumes lorsqu'il
s'en vont amandine infirmières ce qui
m'est déjà arrivé de sortir le d'une
chambre ampleur ça
la situation ou qu'on peut traduire
d'horribles un peu entre dieu et elle
encore surprennent pansements sur une
jambe parce que sur une jambe d'une
jeune femme
cet été nous prêtons moral avant
imputation notre élément compliqué c'est
la confrontation à la souffrance
l'anxiété des patients les souffrance
existentielle
cécile d'être soi même temps impératif
lorsqu'il peut être usant dans son
métier c'est que notamment que ça puisse
être les patients les familles parfois
ont atteint 2 qu'on trouve des solutions
nairas à leurs difficultés d'aller vers
la mort alors donc ils valises aide
soignante ce qui est se trouve pour moi
qui ai le plus compliqué sera la
confrontation à la douleur de ceux qui
restent plus que la confrontation et la
douleur de ceux qui partent un verger
des infirmières s'occupent de l'autre en
fait toute la journée
voilà donc ça c'est vraiment c'est notre
travail et c'est ce qui peut être
fatigant on rentre chez nous puis
on reprend notre vie j'allais dire et on
s'est occupé de l'autre pendant huit
heures donc il y a
peut-être les enfants à la maison donc
il faut peut-être encore s'occuper de
l'autre notre autre mais et donc c'est
quand même peu difficile c'est de
s'occuper de soi ou de feu retrouver
soi-même
à un moment donné
les soignants en soins palliatifs vont
baigner dans la souffrance des patients
et des familles qu'ils accompagnent et
vont tricoter du bien pour contenir ses
douleurs et ses souffrances
la rochefoucauld a dit le soleil ni la
mort ne se peuvent regarder fixement
et pourtant c'est le quotidien d'une
équipe de soins palliatifs c'est environ
150 patients que des soignants vont
côtoyer dans une année des soignants qui
vont accompagner une dame de 80 ans qui
n'a plus de famille qui est seul au
monde et qui veut vivre avec l'équipe
une vie où un père de famille qui a des
ados à la maison et qui se retrouve loin
de son épouse pour s'occuper du
quotidien pendant que lui doit faire
face à ses propres douleurs et à sa
propre souffrance et incompréhension de
la situation ou alors un jeune de 26 ans
qui termine sa vie quand il pense elle a
commencé et au quotidien jour après jour
les soignants vont être à l'écouté de
chacun
chacun unique chacun qui se veut unique
en tout cas une famille qui attend du
soignant de la disponibilité de la
compréhension de l'ecoute de la
technique
ce sont des douleurs qui nécessite
d'abord un savoir technique mais la
relation est à la base du soin comme le
dit gibbs
elle ne s'ajoutent pas aux soins elle en
est le coeur
ces soignants vont donc être extrêmement
sollicités dans leur quotidien auprès de
ses patients qui viennent vivre là le
plus dur de leur existence
le plus radical terminal le plus souvent
mais pas qu'eux aussi des épisodes d'une
maladie qui est une maladie qui évolue
sur une longue durée
ils vont donc pouvoir à un moment donné
se sentir fatigué mais d'une fatigue
particulière qu'on appelle fatigue par
compassion c'est un américain figure qui
a forgé ce concept vous connaissez
certainement le mot de burnt beurre note
en fait est quelque chose qui est lié
enfin une forme de fatigue aussi
d'érosion émotionnel mais qui est lié
aux conditions de travail et à la charge
de travail
la fatigue par compassion c'est très
spécifique du soin d'eux c'est une
résultante de ceux de sète ce quotidien
où l'on côtoie la souffrance de l'autre
en continue jour après jour patients
après patients familles après famille et
bien qu'est ce que c'est cette fatigue
par compassion c'est plus d'énergie
fatiguez pas d'énergie des signes
physiques j'ai mal au dos j'ai mal à la
tête je ne dors pas bien et puis je peux
être inquiet aussi parce que ce que
vivent les patients sont des questions
aussi indépendamment des aspects
physiques mais sur le plan plus
psychique ou spirituelles sont des
questions qui traversent le soignant
aussi croyez vous que le soignant le
matin quand il vient mettre sa blouse sa
tenue son pyjama de travail va suspendre
sur le cintre son choeur d'hommes ou
sonam sur le pyjama sous la blouse
il garde son coeur et il partage le
destin nous sommes tous dans le même
bateau
donc cette fatigue par compassion qui se
traduit
physiquement psychologiquement peut
affecter un soignant n'importe quand
dans sa vie et cela vient de sa capacité
à reconnaître la douleur chez l'autre à
avoir de l'empathie l'empathie c'est
cette capacité qu'on a à imaginer la
douleur et la souffrance de l'autre
alors bien sûr on ne ressent pas des
mêmes choses que le patient que le
malade mais on est cette capacité à
imaginer ce qu'il peut ressentir depuis
que l'imagerie fonctionnelle existe il y
à des scientifiques qui se sont penchés
sur ce qui se passe à l'intérieur ce qui
se passe à l'intérieur quand on voit
l'autre souffrir ils ont imaginé une
manipulation qui consiste à présenter à
2 population une population de soignants
et une population de non soignants une
image qui est une image de patients
auxquels on vient planter des aiguilles
d'acupuncture dans le corps en interne
on regarde d'abord il regarde donc sur
le plan fonctionnel anatomique et
fonctionnel ce qui se passe dans leur
système nerveux et voit du côté des
acupuncteurs certains circuits salut
mais qui partagent des qui partagent des
faisceaux ou des zones anatomiques avec
elle les faits sont impliqués dans le
ressenti de la douleur
et puis ils regardent chez les non
soignants ce qui se passe et il voit que
ce sont d'autres circuits qui sont
activés et qui partagent également une
partie des faits sont impliqués dans la
douleur autrement dit nous avons cette
capacité prouvée maintenant par
l'imagerie à imaginer ce que l'autre
peut ressentir quand on le voit souffrir
évidemment on ne partage pas la partie
émotionnelle et quand on est un soignant
on a une capacité liés à la connaissance
à pouvoir mettre à distance quand même
ce que l'autre
mais ce processus n'est absolument pas
un processus d'une solidité de total est
certes on peut mettre à distance mais
pas complètement
cette fatigue par compassion lié à
l'empathie éprouvé jour après jour pour
ces patients et ces familles nous la
prenons en considération
c'est une réalité je n'ai pas de
chiffres à vous donner pour son
évaluation
il y a peu de travaux qui sont réalisés
sur ce sujet mais c'est une réalité
et puis on éprouve tout soi-même un jour
ou l'autre on en fait l'expérience
nous nous préoccupons donc de cette
réalité l'hôpital peut mettre en place
des moyens d'aider les soignants à
lutter contre cette pratique comme des
groupes de parole comme des
organisations de travail et le manager
se préoccupe de l'organisation de
travail parce que ça on sait aussi que
c'est un bon moyen de lutter contre la
fatigue mais nous avons imaginé une
autre façon d'aider les soignants à
vaincre cette fatigue
ceci est né de la rencontre avec les
praticiens en santé naturels de l'école
internationale de bien-être et cette
rencontre a été extrêmement fructueuse
ils nous ont offert
il nous offre puisque nous avons démarré
début 2014 cette collaboration
l'intervention de praticiens sur l'unité
de soins palliatifs un jour par semaine
ce jour là la psychologue est absente
elle a mis à disposition son bureau et
pendant six heures de temps en moyenne
le praticien santé naturelle va
dispenser des soins aux soignants qui se
seront préalablement inscrits sur un
agenda électronique et je ne vous cache
pas que l'agenda est plein
longtemps à l'avance et pendant sept
heures le soignant va venir rencontrer
ce praticien et le praticien va discuter
avec lui et voir ce qu'il ya de plus
compliqué des fois ce sont les odeurs
vous l'avez entendu qui peuvent être
difficiles à supporter et la magie un
petit stick d'huiles essentielles pour
aider à apaiser les tensions
aider à régler peut-être les problèmes
de sommeil aider à se débarrasser aussi
de tout ce qui sur le plan sensorielle a
été pénible pendant l'activité en touche
c'est un métier on travaille avec nos
mains on voit on écoute on s'en est là
ils vont créer un bain de sang sérialité
agréable qui choses extraordinaires non
seulement va permettre aux soignants de
passer un bon moment à la fois un moment
de détente où les tensions vont lâcher
mais également un moment où le soignant
retrouve de l'énergie pour pouvoir
continuer son travail
ils vont créer une sorte de bulle qui
est un moment un endroit est un moment
qui n'appartient qu'aux soignant le
soignant se recentre en prend soin de
lui et il prend soin de lui
le lien qui va se tricoter avec le
praticien santé naturels et indiens qui
choses extraordinaires va profiter aux
patients les soignants interrogés à
l'issue des enquêtes que nous réalisons
pour mesurer leur satisfaction nous
disent que ce qu'ils ont éprouvée
pendant ces séances
eh bien ils vont le réutiliser dans le
soin aux patients le lien qui s'est
tricoter et indiens qui profite à tous
car que nous soyons de ce côté de la
pelote sur ce fil que je cherche pour le
déroulé mais finalement tout est emmêlé
puisque nous sommes tous liés les uns
aux autres que nous soyons du côté de
ceux qui sont debout en bonne santé
libre libre où que nous soyons du côté
de ceux
qui sont allongés et qui comptent sur
nous dans le fond quand on tirera le
film ce ne sera qu'un fils le même fil
comme le dit pierre marie un
aide-soignant de l'unité un soignant
bien soigné prendra bien soin de l'autre
et tout ceci afin que la fatigue par
compassion puisse se transformer en
satisfaction par compassion